[Música]
dicen que la empresa del futuro va a
tener dos empleados un perro y una
persona
la persona le va a dar de comer al perro
y el perro se va a ocupar de que la
persona no toque las máquinas
la idea de que los robots van a
reemplazar a las personas en el trabajo
no es nueva yo me dedico a la
informática hace más de 15 años pero
esto viene de mucho antes desde la
primera revolución industrial empezaron
a aparecer evoluciones tecnológicas que
amenazaban trabajos que hasta el momento
eran realizados por personas por citar
un ejemplo no tan cercano hace ya varias
décadas vimos la desaparición de los
operadores y operadoras telefónicos esas
personas que las llamadas les decías con
quién quería hablar y se ocupaban de
hacer las conexiones correctas para que
se pueda establecer esa comunicación
veo que hay más de uno que había hablado
con una operadora no
la realidad es que últimamente nos
encontramos cada vez más con noticias de
empresas que anuncian que van a
reemplazar personas por robots
conocen foxconn
foxconn es la fábrica de componentes
electrónicos más grandes del mundo
muchos de los celulares que tenemos
ahora en el bolsillo fueron fabricados
ahí hace unos años
foxconn anunció que iba a reemplazar
60.000 trabajadores por robots
piensen por un momento 60 mil personas
que se fueron ese día a su casa sin
trabajo sabiendo que el otro día lo que
estaban haciendo le iba empezar a hacer
un robot quizás mejor
terrible no
la realidad que quizás no tanto la
empresa anunció un año después que la
prueba fue tan exitosa que para el 2021
planea no tener ningún empleado en la
fábrica y que sea solamente operada por
robots
la realidad es que con la evolución
tecnológica cada vez más tareas
repetitivas o automatizables pueden
empezar a ser desarrolladas por robots
máquinas aplicaciones y esto pasó
siempre pero pareciera ser que ahora la
magnitud de ese recambio parece ser un
poco mayor
pero sólo tareas automatizables pueden
realizar las máquinas
esta es una de las tapas de la revista
newsweek del año mil 997 en la tapa
garry kasparov campeón mundial de
ajedrez
la última resistencia del cerebro desde
la tapa
en ese momento deep blue un software
desarrollado por ibm desafiaba a
kasparov al mejor de seis partidos de
ajedrez
y le gano
era la primera vez que una máquina
vencía a un campeón mundial de ajedrez
en un desafío de este tipo y yo creo que
simbólicamente representa esta época un
antes y un después en la relación entre
las personas y las máquinas hasta ese
momento muchos se escudaban en la idea
de que las máquinas podían hacer tareas
repetitivas pero no podían pensar o
tomar decisiones
pareciera ser que no
vamos a una situación similar pero más
cercana
este es el campeón mundial de go
el juego es un juego similar al ajedrez
pero más complejo un legendario juego
oriental de estrategia
en el año 2016 una empresa de google se
animó a desafiar al campeón de go con su
nueva inteligencia artificial alfa go al
mejor de 5 partidos
imagina quién ganó
así la máquina 41 pero lo interesante
este triunfo es que a pesar de las
similitudes con deep blue al fago fue
desarrollado de una manera distinta los
programadores no le enseñaron al fago
cuál era la estrategia para ganar sino
que solamente le enseñaron las reglas
del go y le pidieron que empieza a
observar un montón de partidos para
aprender y diseñar su propia estrategia
en el segundo partido hay un momento
clave en que la máquina es un movimiento
magistral que cambia el futuro de ese
partido que terminaría ganando
me interesa tía que vean las reacciones
de algunas personas que estaban en ese
momento el primero es el muchacho que
iba repitiendo lo que veía en pantalla y
hacía el movimiento que le sugería la
máquina en el tablero bien vean como él
a pesar de que todo el tiempo ponía las
fichas se va a detener por un segundo
antes apoyar la ficha
porque no puede crear lo que le está
pidiendo la máquina
pero vean ahora las reacciones de los
comentaristas de los relatores vean sus
caras sus expresiones se escuchen
dicen los comentaristas rencores vean
las caras de éstos
no entienden no sabe dónde para las
fechas es un movimiento muy sorprendente
arrugas y el otro se ríe y dice pensé
que la máquina se había equivocado pero
lo que más quiero que vean es la
reacción del icedel quiso el destino que
en ese momento él había salido a
descansar justo cuando la máquina hace
este movimiento
vean lo que pasa cuando se sienta vean
su cara
su desconcierto
otro comentarista dijo más tarde este no
fue un movimiento humano jamás una
persona hubiera hecho ese movimiento
hermoso
así que si pensaban que las máquinas
podían hacer podían pensar pero no
podían aprender
tampoco
muchos estaban pensando que tiene que
quedar un lugar para las personas y
estoy casi seguro que algunos imaginarán
que se trata del arte
y la creatividad
no me vas a decir que una máquina puede
escribir puede pintar puede bailar
[Música]
por qué
aquí
ya no se baila mejor que yo seguro
esta pintura la hizo una inteligencia
artificial y en japón unos programadores
le dieron a un software le pidieron que
lea un montón de bestsellers y le dieron
la instrucción de escribir la mejor
novela posible luego presentaron la
novela en un concurso literario y
llegaron a la final
así que si pensaban que las máquinas
pueden hacer pueden pensar pueden
aprender pero no pueden ser creativas
que sea tan poco
entonces y ahora
creo que nos queda una idea más quizás
nos queda la calidez la simpatía la
empatía siempre es mejor hablar con una
persona que hablar con un robot
escuchen este fragmento de esta
conversación telefónica están los
subtítulos abajo
[Música]
antena maker
en igual dato
parece una conversación telefónica
normal entre dos personas
son dos personas una de las dos en una
máquina una inteligencia artificial y de
hecho en este momento no saben cuál de
las dos era en este caso era la persona
la mujer que pedía el turno pero podría
haber sido al revés
como sea pareciera ser que las máquinas
están evolucionando y pueden también
hacer calidad con una persona quizás más
cuantas veces vamos a un local y nos
atienden con tanta mala onda que
preferiríamos que nos atiende una
máquina
nos estamos ocupando nosotros en nuestro
trabajo de que nuestros compañeros
nuestros clientes prefieran hablar con
nosotros que interactuar con una máquina
pero entonces si pensaban que las
máquinas podían hacer podían pensar
podían aprender podían ser creativas
pero no podían ser simpáticas
tampoco
entonces a qué mundo nos enfrentamos
qué lugar nos queda las personas
pagar trabajo para todos porque
pareciera hacer
que quizás no como nos preparamos
entonces para el futuro no tan lejano
del trabajo
yo no soy muy muy amigo de las ciudades
extremas
por cada robot que aparezca quizás
detrás hay personas creando esa robot
ingenios mecánicos desarrolladores de
software diseñadores por citar un
ejemplo por eso es que no me gustan las
ideas apocalípticas yo no me imagino un
futuro donde sólo trabajen los robots y
las personas no
lo que estoy seguro es que el mundo
laboral va a cambiar mucho los próximos
años que muchos trabajos van a
desaparecer pero otros tantos se van a
transformar y otras tantos van a
aparecer y todavía no sabemos muy bien
la magnitud entre estos lo que sí
sabemos es suficiente para ocuparnos en
todos los niveles el sector estatal
público el sector corporativo las
empresas las instituciones educativas
pero también nosotros como individuos
como personas y eso es lo que me
interesa a mí hoy así que me animé a
compartirla es mi opinión en formato de
autoayuda con ustedes estos cinco
consejos para que un robot no tome su
trabajo vamos
el primero
no elegir la carrera incorrecta
mucho se habla de elegir la carrera
correcta yo les conté que me dedico a la
informática a veces estoy 5 o 6 meses
para lograr cubrir una vacante en mi
equipo porque no encuentro un experto en
seguridad forma tica para la posición
mientras veo por la calle colas de
cientos de personas compitiendo por unos
escasos puestos laborales por eso que
mucha gente habla de las carreras
tecnológicas como las carreras del
futuro y por supuesto que algo de razón
tienen es una realidad pero aún así a mí
me parece que no es suficiente y por eso
me gusta dar vuelta a la ecuación para
mí lo más importante de bases al menos
no elegir la carrera incorrecta a qué me
refiero representa un sitio web se llama
wheel robots text mind show back van a
tomar los robots mi trabajo en este
sitio con una interfaz muy sencilla lo
único que puedes hacer cuando entras es
poner tu trabajo tu profesión tu oficio
y el sitio calcula y te da cuán probable
es que un robot ocupe tu trabajo
se imaginan algunos algunos oficios
algunas profesiones que podrían ser
fácilmente reemplazadas por un robot o
que es muy probable cada uno estará
pensando no hay grava que se está
volviendo cada vez más evidente y hace
unos años no era tanto que son los
cajeros las personas que cobran en la
caja cada vez hay menos dinero físico
cada vez el dinero es más digital y acá
cada vez es más fácil
pagar en una máquina y por eso es que
los cajeros se puede estimar que hay un
97 por ciento de probabilidad de que
sean reemplazados
por eso es que yo creo que se trata de
al menos evitar elegir este tipo de
oficios este tipo de profesiones hace
poco el banco interamericano de
desarrollo hizo una encuesta donde la
mayoría de las personas indicaron que
era acordaron que era muy probable que
los robots reemplacen a las personas en
el trabajo pero sólo un grupo muy
pequeño indicó que eso quería que los
afectaba a ellos en su trabajo
por eso yo creo que para que no nos
afecte en nuestros propios juicios o
nuestros propios deseos es bueno usar
fuentes externas y este sitio es una no
es un valor final no es un valor para
tomar lo tallado en piedra pero sí puede
ser un buen comienzo para hacernos una
idea sobre qué profesiones tienen más o
menos futuro y eventualmente investigar
un poco más
y no se trata solamente de las carreras
tecnológicas por ejemplo hay muchas
personas hablan de que la enfermería es
una profesión que en el futuro va a ser
tan necesaria como lo es hoy en día y es
poco probable que sean reemplazadas por
robots
tampoco se trata solamente de un tema
para jóvenes de 18 y 20 años que tienen
que elegir que estudiar muchos de los
que ya estamos inmersos en el mundo
laboral ante los cambios que se vienen
vamos a tener que pensar y preguntarnos
si en el momento de adaptarnos o
reinventarnos
vamos al consejo número 2 consejo número
2 aprender toda la vida
hasta hace no tanto lo que estudiamos
entre los 18 y los 25 años nos definía
para siempre
ya no más
se sabe que muchas de las cosas que
aprendemos especialmente cuando
aprendemos a hacer algo cada vez es útil
por menos tiempo cada vez nos dura menos
la validez de lo que aprendemos los
conocimientos al mismo tiempo ya
hablamos que en paralelo las máquinas
pueden estar todo el tiempo aprendiendo
y mejorando es por eso que es necesario
aprender toda la vida y no hablo de
estar haciendo una carrera universitaria
todo el tiempo
hablo de una actitud de una
predisposición
la primera predisposición es a darnos
cuenta cuando algo que estamos haciendo
tiene fecha de vencimiento a darnos
cuenta cuando algo que sabemos no va a
ser más necesario en el futuro y a
partir de eso ver cómo podemos aprender
cosas nuevas desde hacer cursos cortos
hasta leer hasta investigar hasta una
constante predisposición a preguntar y
consultar
y no hablo solamente de aprender toda la
vida en una cuestión temporal de a qué
edad sino creo que también espacial
solemos ver a la escuela o la
universidad como el lugar donde se
aprende y al trabajo donde se aplica lo
aprendido
yo creo que tenemos que empezar a pensar
entornos laborales donde el aprendizaje
constante esté presente hace poco leí
una frase que decía que los analfabetos
del siglo 20 eran aquellos que no sabían
leer ni escribir pero los analfabetos
del siglo 21 van a ser los que sean
incapaces de desaprender y aprender algo
nuevo
consejo número 3
y desarrollar habilidades blandas
no se trata solamente de cuánto
aprendemos sino también de que elegimos
aprender
el foro económico mundial publicó hace
no tanto una lista de habilidades que
son importantes para esta cuarta
revolución industrial que estamos
viviendo
cuando estamos haciendo para ser
profesionales con sentido crítico con
habilidades de negociación con
inteligencia emocional
cuán buenos somos para trabajar en
equipo
no hay dudas que las habilidades duras
van a ser mucho más propensas a hacer a
ser reemplazadas por un robot por una
máquina
y a pesar de que vimos que las máquinas
pueden ser creativas sin lugar a dudas
las habilidades blandas van a ser las
que sostengan y haga la diferencia en el
futuro que se viene
consejo número 4
no se trata solamente de los trabajos
sino también de las tareas muchas de las
publicaciones que vemos a este tipo
incluso el sitio que les mostré antes
hablan del trabajo va a desaparecer el
trabajo va a seguir estando y yo no creo
que el futuro sea tan simple todos
nuestros trabajos pueden ser vistos como
una acumulación de tareas
es por eso importante que miremos esas
tareas y las y las pensemos
individualmente para ver cuáles son más
propensas o no a ser reemplazadas por
una máquina y quizás si eso es un cajero
que estás cobrando ya no sea necesario
que hagas el intercambio de dinero
porque lo podría hacer una máquina pero
puede que las personas sigamos queriendo
que otra persona con calidez con empatía
y con criterio nos aconseje qué producto
comprar
yo no sé cuántos trabajos van a
desaparecer pero si estoy casi seguro
que casi todos van a cambiar
entonces ver en qué tareas ponemos en
juego nuestras habilidades blandas es
una muy buena pista de hacia dónde puede
evolucionar nuestros trabajos
quinto y último consejo el que le da
título a esta charla
no sigas tu pasión
cuando nos
elige que estudiar yo creo que hay dos
tipos de consejeros el tipo a el tío la
tía que te dicen que estudies abogacía
psicología contabilidad porque si no no
vas a tener trabajo
pero también está muy de moda el tipo b
el primo la prima jóvenes que te dan ese
consejo directo al corazón
seguí tu pasión
hace un tiempo me preguntaron qué
consejo le daría a estudiantes de
secundaria para elegir su carrera y lo
primero que me salió fue esto seguí tu
pasión
pero mientras lo escribía me puse a
pensar en mi carrera
era mi pasión la informática a los 17
años
un poco pero no tanto como tocar la
guitarra o escribir
me apasionaba el mundo del hacking y la
seguridad informática al que hoy me
dedico en ese momento no para nada
conocí a ese mundo un año y medio
después en una charla optativa en la
universidad
peor aún me apasionaba llamar a la gente
cuando estaban ocupados para ofrecerles
líneas telefónicas y conexiones de
internet cuando me postulé a mi primer
pasantía como telemarketer
no
y este trabajo fue muy importante para
mi carga de aprendí un montón y terminé
dedicándome a lo mío a lo mío en esa
misma empresa
entonces me quedé pensando
que quizás el consejo de seguir tu
pasión era mucho más fácil dar lo que
seguirlo
todos sabemos cuál es nuestra pasión a
los 17 años
peor aún todos sabemos a cualquier edad
cuál es nuestra pasión cuántos ejemplos
hay de gente que encuentra su pasión a
cualquier edad
pero en este momento pensando que él
estaba errando con el consejo apareció
mi cabeza lo que para mí fue revelador
y que yo quiero compartir con ustedes
no se trata de seguir tu pasión se trata
de ser apasionado
no sigas tu pasión sea apasionado
porque ahí está la clave si sos
apasionado tarde o temprano vas a
encontrar tu pasión y la gente
apasionada es la que tarde o temprano en
este mundo tan cambiante va a ser la
diferencia
no seas tu pasión sea apasionado puede
que los robots pueden hacer pensar
aprender ser creativos o ser empáticos
pero yo todavía no vio un robot
apasionado
puede que aparezca
no lo sé mientras tanto yo me animo a
venir acá ya defender un poco las
personas con la bandera de la pasión
el mundo está cambiando mucho y la
tecnología viene a resolver muchos
problemas
y puede que necesitemos a los robots
pero yo creo que vamos a necesitar
muchísimo más a la gente apasionada
el futuro no es humanos contra robots
el futuro va a ser humanos trabajando
con robots
y la pregunta
es en qué lugar va a estar cada uno de
nosotros o si se me permite en qué lugar
eligen estar cada uno de ustedes
garry kasparov
aquel ajedrecista que representó la
última resistencia del cerebro humano
frente a las máquinas y que perdió
dijo muchos años después algo que espero
quede retumbando en sus cabezas como
quedó en la mía desde que lo escuché
tenemos que vencer nuestros miedos para
sacar lo mejor de la tecnología
pero tenemos que conquistar nuestros
miedos para sacar lo mejor de la
humanidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i